hello internet world
this is Bjork this is my first internet
vlog and um I just I want to talk about
the things that I I do when I'm alone
and things that make me happy
I figured out something very interesting
today you put your hands like this
and you cross your middle fingers and
turn it around and it tells this I just
thought it was funny
I like the sensation of going from a
freezing cold place into a warm place
and you get the shivers on your back for
example I once went into Costco freezer
and then I went into my hot car and it
felt good I collect a lot of figurines
and toys and sometimes I like to lay on
the ground and place them all over my
body and pretend that I'm an island I
have a cat and sometimes I like to
follow her around and pretend that I am
a cat - hi kitty hello kitty play with
me if I weren't a cat I would sneak up
on you I could be a cat if I really want
to I could scare you away and make no
friends I could be a scared
it's all so simple the other day I
didn't play with instruments but simply
the toilet seat cover and my shower
curtain at the same time and I created
some beats now get away Oh get away I
know that there is something more in my
heart a fun are the trees well everyone
that's it for today's björk block I will
be back with more I hope that you enjoy
as much as I have